joe judge and anyone who is beginning as
a head coach can only hope to be as
successful
as our first guest today was in the nfl
his uh success as coach of the
buccaneers in the colts landed him in
the pro football hall of fame he is tony
dungy of football night in america
and he joins us now good morning coach
how are you hey mike and chris i'm
telling you it is crazy i'm
thinking back to my first year in 96 my
biggest decision was what airline did we
want to use to charter our flights
messed up for about two i can't imagine
well and you know but before we get into
the nuts and bolts of how it works from
a coaching perspective given everything
that's going on
just give us your personal thoughts on
what has sparked the latest overlap
between society and sports
with george floyd's murder i think we
all thought that maybe things were going
to be different that maybe
change was coming that maybe people
realized that police officers realized
the limits of using
lethal force and now here we are as
labor day approaches
following what happened on memorial day
it
we have another incident and it's hard
for me to process whether any progress
at all has been made what's been your
reaction to what happened to jacob blake
well it's difficult and i i never like
to jump to conclusions the video doesn't
look good
you've got to see the whole thing and
the whole picture and uh
you know it's just it's sad that we're
in this that
every week or every month we're gonna
have something that that sparks and i'll
cry so
it's difficult i try to put myself on
both sides and
see the whole picture uh but it's hard
and everybody's upset
and the fact that we've got all this
video now is
the game changer no question about it
coach so
you're coaching the tampa bay buccaneers
the indianapolis colts
you know that pla this is on players
minds right now it's it's part of our
society
what are you doing today as you walk
into the locker room and have that team
meeting
you know what's the approach you take as
as a head coach in this in these
circumstances
well i think what's happening in the nfl
i'm sure is
you know people are saying here's what
the nba is doing here's what major
league baseball is doing here's what
mls is doing and players are going to
ask what are we going to do what should
we do
and you've got to have those discussions
and
when when we did i always tried to make
the point to my players
what are we going to do to make it
better what is the solution
let's not just say hey we've got to shut
down because everybody else is
uh everybody's doing this we're going to
do that what can we do
to make a difference and what's our next
steps
i'm curious with the nba what is
when are they going to go back and play
what do they need to see happen
before they play what's the next step
that that's what you've got to know
yeah and coach i almost feel like the
nfl teams are going to watch very
carefully what the nba
does and that there may be a delayed
impact
if the nba just shuts the season down
that that sets the stage for a new set
of decisions
to be made by the players but uh
i i guess from a coach's perspective i
mean if you're listening to your locker
room how much control do you really have
over that situation i mean
well i i you haven't been in that spot
for 12 years now
but how would you go about trying to
balance out the various interests and
try to reach some sort of a conclusion
where everyone's on the same page you
know you got to talk to everybody and
again it depends on
who the leader of the team is and in
most cases in the nfl
the leader is is the head coach uh
you've got some star players and
obviously they're going to have a big
impact but in most cases uh
it's the head coach that's not true in
every sport you know and that that's not
true especially in the nba
i i was reading online yesterday someone
said hey well the teams voted
and everybody decided this some teams
decided that lebron james
isn't going to play if lebron james
makes a decision he is very much the
leader of the
the los angeles lakers there's no
question about that so
i think every situation is a little bit
different
coach like as a you know nbc analyst
right now
ex-coach i mean what would you like the
nfl what would you like to see the nfl
do
you know moving forward you know to to
help the players out help this cause out
do you think it should be a team by team
like individual team effort or would you
like to see the nfl get more involved in
this
conversation and take a little bit more
of a proactive approach
well i'd like to see everybody come into
it and have a conversation
and try to figure out where we're going
to go from here in the direction
but again i'm not one that says hey
we've got to do this because everybody
else is doing it the nba did this so
we've got to do the same thing
come together figure out a plan what can
we do to be a voice for people who don't
have a voice
what can we do that's going to be
effective and what is our end point what
would we like to see
uh what do we want to see happen and
come up with a plan that way
and i hope the nfl can do that uh in
conjunction with the players
see that that's where i struggle with
the coach because i think the players
ultimately just
want what's happening to stop
and how do we ever know that we've
reached that
finish line there is no point where we
can say
we've arrived we've finally affected
meaningful change
because we're just one news cycle away
from the next video
that shows an unarmed black man being
shot in the back or otherwise brutalized
by police and then it all
comes back again right and that that's
the thing that i think we have to come
to in this we can't say
because an incident happens we haven't
made progress
or nothing nothing has changed uh if
every time something happens uh we're
going to have a shutdown
we'll never have any season because
things are going to happen we live in a
fallen world it's not perfect
you're going to have problems yeah i get
it and we don't want to see it
but what what is the solution you know
what is the
end point that we're looking for and i
think that's what we've got to come up
with
coach all right now we got another issue
we got to talk about and i'm dying to
get your two cents about this
you know pandemic football nfl
right now i mean it's we're two weeks
away from playing football i can't
believe that i feel like guys just
started practicing
but you know just give us uh give us a
clue of
maybe what you've heard or what what
head coaches are trying to go through
right now dealing with the
that the pandemic covet 19 circumstance
it's definitely different uh you've
disrupted people cycle for years we've
been used to hey off season
program and give them a little break
come back together
training camp i've got my six weeks of
how we're gonna do it
and now everything is different and no
one knows
you know how it's gonna be next week
that's the problem
i know when i was coaching warren sapp
used to say
i'm the only person that can tell you
what i'm going to be doing
tuesday a year from now because you know
we know and we plan on it
well now you can't do it that way it is
hey we're gonna have to roll with the
punches we're gonna have to adjust
something could happen that we we can't
foresee and that's difficult when when
you're not used to doing it that way
um my son i just you know started high
football and um
i'm out there watching them practice
they've got a game coming up a week from
tomorrow
and they never assumed that was going to
happen
and they just started practicing is it
going to take place i'm not really sure
and i think that's where the nfl is yeah
we've got all the confidence that it's
going to go
we're all looking forward to
broadcasting september 10th but
is it really going to take place i don't
think we'd all bet our houses on it
right now that we're going to have a
game we think we are
but that's what that's the problem but
how do you
balance like you know no off season guys
are starting to drop like flies with
injuries
yet okay your great coach tony dungy
also pushing your team to get in
football shape
and how do you balance the amount of
schematics you throw on to everybody
here
in this short time like kind of what
would be your approach you know with all
that coach
i would really that would be a problem
for me because
you are wanting to get the guys ready
you're wanting to push them but you
can't push too hard
you also know that hey if i send these
guys out there uh
at game speed and they haven't had
enough work we're going to have more
problems
and how do you balance that i haven't
really done that before
um i i think we're in a lot of uncharted
water and
coaches i don't think they have the
answers
yeah and you know on top of the concerns
about getting the team ready
about keeping the virus out of the
facility
you know now we've got this mixed bag of
some teams will have fans some teams
won't we've had respected coaches like
mike zimmer the vikings and sean
mcdermott the bills
speak out against the competitive
imbalance what would your thoughts be
about
entering a season where you very well
may have no fans in your building
and then you're going to play on the
road and they're going to have 15 20 000
fans there
and it just feels like it's not across
the board fair to everyone
i wouldn't really worry about that that
to me has been
uh football since the beginning of time
you play in pittsburgh
you play in baltimore there's going to
be a raucous crowd you play in new
england there's going to be a raucous
crowd seattle
other places don't have that kind of fan
support
i remember playing games in kansas city
when i was in pittsburgh
there was nobody in the stands and then
we'd uh return a kickoff for a punt
and the people that were there would
leave so you know that's happened
deal with that um i don't think that's
an issue
what's going to happen on the field
what's going to happen if all of a
sudden
my quarterback has a false positive but
he can't play in the game
i'd be more concerned about that than
whose fans
are there or any of that are we going to
have crowd noise or not
coach i've heard you make the comment
that this would be
a year you'd want a veteran established
type quarterback
uh and you had peyton this is the kind
of year you want a peyton manning i'm
sure he'd be driving you crazy during
this whole thing right now going we need
more plays more practice whatever it is
but just give us your thoughts there on
why you say that about the veteran
quarterback
no question you can't do as much work
as you would like to do you can't get
everybody as prepared and those
quarterbacks that know what they're
doing
they can be the eraser they can fix
things uh that
that need to get fixed and the coach
can't handle it
uh i think the tom brady's and i've
talked to some of my buddies over
at the box and they say it's
unbelievable how the practices are
different just how
everybody's paying attention how tom's
got this offense
geared in and he hasn't even been there
six weeks
but that veteran presence knowing what
he wants
uh has been sensational so i i think the
teams that have their quarterback in
place or the
the coach that's been there the bill
belichick's they're gonna have a huge
advantage in this
setup and really if you put the two
together with consistency in the
coaching staff and consistency in the
roster
like the team we start the season with
as they raise their first banner in 50
years
this just sets up perfectly for the
kansas city chiefs to pick up where they
left off doesn't it coach
no question about it if you've got the
same coach in place you've got most of
your
uh key players back you've got your
veteran quarterback in place
it that's who i would go down the list
and say hey if
we're looking for favorites in the
league the way it's going that that's
who i want to bet on
no question coach what are you expecting
like week one i mean because i'm there's
a part of me that goes oh we could see a
lot of sloppy play and a lot of
quarterback sacks because offensive
lines aren't going to be ready for
all of that but i also think about the
year of you know 2012 with no offseason
we had
three 5 000 yard passers and it seemed
like offense kind of took off like
if you just had to assess right now what
kind of play do you expect to see
early on in the regular season i think
you are going to see sloppy play you're
going to see
uh inconsistencies you're going to see
some upsets
you're going to see a lot of injuries as
people start to go
full speed for maybe the first time in a
while and i think you're going to see
some teams
light it up because the offenses do have
a little advantage
tom brady could take his guys to
berkeley prep
school uh here in tampa and work with
them
and throw and get seven or eight guys
who are really on the same page
the defenses can't necessarily do that
so i think you are going to see the
offenses ahead of the defenses for a
while
but i think it's going to be a little
bit sloppy at the beginning and i would
look for those veteran quarterbacks to
light things up early
coach here's one i have for you that
i've been thinking about getting your
opinion on and
i'm torn on this the commissioner has an
outside advisory committee including
your former colleague bill polian from
the colts
and they have created this eight person
outside committee to assist with
making tough decisions that may be
necessitated by the pandemic up to and
including
maybe pulling the plug on a game maybe
postponing maybe canceling maybe having
some teams
that have fewer than 16 games by the
time we get to the end of the season
i look at football and i say this is the
ultimate next man
up sport and it's on the team to have
its players ready it's on the team to
have enough
healthy offensive lineman to have enough
members of the practice squad
who are versatile who can play o-line
d-line receivers who can play d-back
different things you can do a kicker who
can punt a punter who can kick the
things you can do to make sure you have
enough players
to go so you never have to say sorry we
just can't play today how do you feel
about that balance between
saying to the teams hey here's when the
game is we'll see you there with your 46
players or whoever you can put in
uniform
versus the possibility of the
commissioner saying we're going to give
this team a dispensation and not play
today
i think with the people that are on that
committee i think that's what you're
going to see mike for the most part
that's going to be their recommendation
yes you've got to get it going yet it's
going to be tough but you've got to
handle it some way i think what this is
going to be in place for is that thing
that
nobody can predict what happens when
something happens that no one saw
coming is that fair is it safe
uh you know to do and and that's where i
think this committee is going to have
recommendations and the commissioner is
going to have to decide hopefully it
never gets to that
hopefully yeah hey this team lost six
guys tough
i mean we played a game my last year
with the
the colts we had 39 guys i think that
could were available
and i'm saying guys they've got 44 we've
got 39
but that's football and it happens and
you got to go out there
and and make it happen but is there
something that happens that
is totally unforeseen uh then i think
that's where you'll see the committee
come into play
all right full transparency usually when
we have our nbc
sunday night football meetings coach
dungy goes into his car because he's
scared of what i might say
and the swears i might say so he doesn't
want his family and kids to hear that
but i'm on tv today you knew you were
safe all right but you still went to the
car huh coach
i'm in the car i just had to drop off
but i i will say this
uh you're i think you got my kids
prepared justin went to his first
practice last week and uh
i just said nicely you prepared him for
high school
good i'm glad i can help out the dungey
family i heard more four-letter words in
the practice
ten minutes than i heard on my uh last
13 years of coaching so
uh and how's justin doing as he gets
ready for high school football
you know what it's it's a lot of fun uh
our last
high school player was 10 years ago now
i guess so
uh it's kind of neat to be back in the
swing of things to be out there on the
sideline with other parents and to get
ready we've got a game coming up a week
from
uh friday a week from tomorrow so it's
kind of exciting again he's fired up
wants to play quarterback i wish he
would play another position but he
thinks he's going to be baker mayfield
so
i love it what does the coach do when
hall of fame coach tony dungy
approaches the facility because if it
was me i'd run into my car and hide i'd
say here coach you take the whistle i
can't
i can't even come close to doing what
you can do well i try to stay
you know i try to stay away from things
as much as possible and just be
in the background i know i wouldn't want
to put any type of pressure on anyone
else but
most of these coaches know me and so
it's been pretty good
i do remember eric my oldest son though
as an eighth grader
we're in indianapolis and their their
first game uh i told
you know our guys knew about it so
peyton
reggie wayne and edrin james went to the
game and i i don't think the kids could
play they were eighth graders and ever
you know they were just looking at the
sideline the whole time those three guys
so
i hope i bring that type of distraction
well coach we appreciate your input and
your insight as always we wish you and
your family all the best and we look
forward to talking to you again real
soon
all righty thank you mike chris can't
wait uh hopefully uh
in a couple of weeks we're broadcasting
you know it you're the man coach good
seeing you all right
all right there he is hall of fame head
coach tony dungy when we return
mike tarico from nbc's football night in
america joins the discussion we'll be
back with tarico on pft live right after
this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports